culture avec le talent et l'imaginaire
de ce chorégraphe flamand le plus doué
de sa génération vie me vendre des quais
bus qui propose au théâtre de la ville
sa dernière création où il met en scène
et l'énergie la dynamique presque la
violence à fleur de peau de ses danseurs
michel sur le vice et d'idées dans
l'énergie au poste de commandement
l'énergie en sautoir
c'est l'avis rageuse et trépidante que
nous insuffle la compagnie de wismes
vandekeybus de cette scène transformée
en arène
dernière fois c'est le nom en forme de
manifeste de cette troupe comme un appel
à vivre intensément chaque moment une
danse au bord du gouffre
retrouvons donc notre vigueur pour
bousculer nos habitudes et le monde
s'est tu cherches faire cette énergie
qui est un peu perdue que moi je veux
faire vivre c'est cette énergie positive
qui peut bien sûr s'ils donnaient un
commentaire sur toute la violence qui se
passe avec une indifférence presque dans
les guerres et de tout ce qui se passe
dans le monde mais je pense que cette
intensification de d'énergie à très
important pour moi je veux papeete c'est
l'histoire d'un rêve où l'homme se débat
au milieu de ses angoisses
de ses espoirs
m
de ces zones dont peu
hop un lieu propice aux désirs
m